um i want to let you know though i got
some new tour dates that you can check
out
and i'm grateful for them uh february
2nd i'll be in jacksonville florida
the third
st petersburg
uh the fifth i'll be in orlando the 24th
i'll be in
lafayette indiana the 25th rockford
illinois home of the rockford peaches
and that's america's team right there
female ball
february 26 chicago illinois
uh
may 6th in tulsa may 7th in los angeles
today's guest is a wonderful man and um
and he is the number
eight ranked ufc bantamweight
uh fighter
he's a fighting man and
and a family man he's a he's a lot of
types of man
and um he is the pride of ecuador
uh the country of ecuador and of america
as well
uh i'm very grateful for his time today
it is mr marlon cheeto vera for me to
set
[Music]
my up
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
and i will find a song
[Applause]
dude thanks for coming in man thank you
for having brother yeah bro you're so
exciting man i feel like you're like one
of the most exciting guys to be
like
whenever i watch you i almost feel like
i need to go for a run or something
because i feel like my energy gets
just watching you like my energy gets up
you know um i got pretty high energy
dude like i when i get to the cage for
me it's not about
just winning the fight i want you
i'm a performer you know it's like a
movie for me i want to go in there and
let's just make it like
yeah like you got in there and did
enough to win i want to take your head
off clean i don't i'm not trying so hard
for that i don't i don't train for like
just get away with it i tried to like
clean cut damn boy damn you want to take
them down like a lumberjack i i train
that's all i do you know what i'm saying
like i feel like most fighters sometimes
uh
they think they should work when they
call them to fight
i trained year round that's my job i
don't
i don't have a second job i used to have
a second job when when i didn't make
money but now that this is my life this
is everything i do for living
it's year-round like i turn monday
through monday there's no
seasons because we don't have a season
in the ufc like tomorrow they can tell
me like hey
the top the the
from from five to number four
everybody's in your or everybody's book
i can't fight for the bell next i don't
know what's gonna happen like somebody
can get copied somebody can get hurt and
they call the guy that is below next so
you got to be ready for me it's like
just being ready like my only job is to
fight well
i'm ready to fight at any moment wow
do um you said you had another job at
one point what was that other job you
had dude it was some [ __ ] awful job
um it was it was like like kind of like
work for the city hall it was like a
governmental stuff yeah and like chasing
was it like animal catching or something
i wish dude that would be nice my shirt
was like
sitting on a boot and
it was like a window and everybody
brings papers like legal stuff like a
bunch of lawyers coming in and now
people that put uh
i don't know let's see you stole my card
you bring the paper saying that the
the cub report and my job was to take
the paper and and put it in specific
folders like crime i don't know a small
smaller team small crime mysteries or
whatever from from from something huge
to something small and my job was
usually grab a paper and put in a folder
and these people was like hey it's been
the third time what the [ __ ] like is
your phone like
[ __ ] my i could pay like 300 a month
like my job is to grab the paper and put
in here like if you have an issue go
inside and go talk to i don't know to
where the [ __ ] lost here like yes
somebody i'm nobody here and
wow my job was the shitty job
i sort of got i would rather clean the
floors
than do that because
every day somebody was mad because their
their
their stuff wasn't being processed
and they would tell me to [ __ ] off or
[ __ ] you you don't do you're like
i'm using paper guys i just grab papers
and put it on and one and one day snap
and i use you did snap i and what
happened on a man or woman
a guy i will never stop one lady well
most of them i wouldn't but once in a
while maybe i'm a lover yeah i'm like
with the ladies all respect you know i
can my dad teach me good manners but
yeah this guy was like
treating me like a piece of [ __ ]
and yeah i guess he was like a like like
a big time lawyer whatever and i just
when he dropped he just throw the
peppers and when he was leaving i was
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] and he walked
around but he didn't knew
i was a fighter yeah i was a guy trying
to be in the ufc one day and he came
around like what you said i was like i
was just like
dude
you know it's not this is not your dad
trust me yeah and then he just walked
away basically saying i will kick your
ass
he wouldn't do [ __ ]
but then that guy was probably friends
with somebody high
in the it's not a company's uh
um just business
in a building oh fancy people like rich
people yeah i guess and then i get
kicked out in that moment you got kicked
up but you didn't hit the guy no i i
wish i hit it because i was getting
kicked out was i was like but when they
when when they kicked me i was like
thank god i just you know i just i keep
trying
i was free but there was no money right
so i have to go back to my data
basically hey i need some help like
help me and then my dad was like okay
i'm gonna help you
this is the last year i helped you i was
like
19. but i was already married i already
have a daughter so it's like hey this is
the last year i'm going to help you
to to get your fantasy ufc whatever your
dream but
when this december you're done with me
and then either you work for me like no
training just work for me
or you find whatever to do with your
life
and literally
my dad put me a day like this december
you're done with me
and the ufc coming november
it was it was just meant to be yeah it's
life when you do so much for something
you will [ __ ] get it no matter what
yeah one of my friends used to say if he
used to ask me he said have you ever
worked really hard for something and not
gotten it
and the answer was no like if it's
something i really really work for
you always get it it's impossible to if
you don't get something it thinks if it
still don't go right in life it's
because either you're not doing enough
or you're doing it wrong oh there's no
way you don't get there if you put
everything together there will be
obstacles there will be bad days there
will be
a setbacks but if you keep on going and
and you really want to make it happen
it's just impossible not to happen facts
wow that's powerful man it is well
especially coming from a guy like you
who's who who's put that to the test in
his own life you know you've burned that
candle and lit up your own future with
uh with it you know um i heard you say
on uh on joe rogan's that um
there were times where you fought where
you didn't even want them to pay you yes
because you just wanted to get your name
out there 100
was
is one of the like why do you think you
fight like i think some people fight for
different reasons this is just me yeah
some people fight they want to be seen
some people
they need to
win some people need to prove something
like do you do you know what it is
inside of you that makes you
yeah i
i love
crazy [ __ ] like
uh when i was a little kid
like for example let me start with this
in in my family
i would call them their normal people
like my dad have a farm he worked the
farm he figured out how to make money
but regular guy he will work
in anywhere to provide for the family
right i saw that as a kid my mom
she she stayed home
make sure the house is clean and nice
make sure the kids me and my two my
brother my sister we're good like you're
just normal
sister and brother graduate we're in
college have normal jobs you know
and but when i was a kid i was just
trying to find my dad guns and play with
them or
just jumping from breaking my arm i was
just looking for to do crazy [ __ ] and
when i was a little kid i was a huge fan
of like rambo or chuck norris and i was
like i want to be like a navy seal i
want to be like a real
badass but
no offense to my country you go to the
military network you're [ __ ] really we
don't even have guns out there like we
have but what they have more swords
maybe yeah a couple machetes yeah you
know we don't have the navy seals
like in here like
here you got like and every single
division and they're all like real
killers
we have a small army it's just different
it's a third world country so i i was
smart enough to be like okay if i really
want to do this
not in my country i love my country till
then but it's just not for me the
military the military so
i will you i will get in street fights
all the time like you know my cousins or
my brother for fun
homeless kids like hey i give you a
couple bucks and you fight my brother
and for me it was a game we would get
like it was an inspiring did you lose
sometimes yeah i get my ass kicked a
thousand times did you ever fight any
grown man or it was just children
um
most were my age but you know they live
in the street they got more experience
they got more everything i was like i
was a kid from my mom would give him my
the phone in my mouth those kids have to
hustle for real yeah those kids they got
a lot more like uh hoof to mouth
a lot of disease and stuff i gotta get a
lot they gotta lie
and then i just like fighting like
and when when i get to see pride that
you've seen everything else like well
that's gonna be my my life i'm gonna
become a fighter one day yeah i heard
you talking about that like whenever you
first saw it you're like whoa this is a
real thing and then it just beckoned you
but so you think you fight because
you just ca you just like anarchy kind
of do you like the insanity of it do you
i love i love all that i love the
process i love the even yesterday when i
was watching the fights life i was like
i was watching and i was like this is
[ __ ] crazy like
i'm an expectator
to two [ __ ] guys in a cage beating
the shade of each other
for
money
and of course you know somebody what
people want to be famous people want to
advance in life you got you want to meet
the cool people you you that you will
never met whatever
it's insane it's like the gladiators
like yeah they call it
two guys fight until then
i'm pretty mean like i'm not i'm not in
there just to like okay i want to be
famous i want to [ __ ] you up yeah
outside the cage i will never get in the
fight unless
the the limits are like push too much
but
i'm not even thinking about it i'm
training all the time
is there fights like is there a fight
that you've that you've been in where
you didn't you still obviously wanted to
where you obviously wanted to win the
fight but the respect level was
different against the guy you were
fighting so it kind of
it maybe wasn't the same type of like
i'm going to kill this guy as much as i
just want to win this match no it's i
keep the same energy like i thought guys
like all the frankie are like yeah yeah
yeah and you know
everybody respect them for me doesn't
matter if the guy talks [ __ ] if the guy
is a quiet guy
if they don't want to shake hands
i just keep it up and
i'm very honest i'm not in there to
shake hands and bow to each other i'm
like
yeah the catch is locked
i'm gonna make sure you're the one
feeling bad afterwards wow and i lost
before i when i lose a father i can i
cannot sleep for months because i
all i do is put everything to win you
know it's an obsession like
because of everything that comes with it
is the money to provide for the family
my house like i'm not just fighting
because it's cool right it's [ __ ] rad
to fight you know the ufc is awesome
celebrities coming around like people
like when i was a kid
i would look up to now i'm friends with
them is
the whole entire circle is cool yeah but
i like fighting even that's your thing i
like fighting do you think that some
fighters there's they start to lose that
focus do you think that there's guys
that it starts to get too much about the
ambiance i think that's it's definitely
gained a lot of track like there's a lot
of i mean i was at
i mean who was there last night i'm sure
there were like i like for example in
from myself like i
mike tyson was there wow like we make
eye contact and he kind of like say hi
and i was like [ __ ] that's the tiger of
the universe right there yeah i was like
holy oh [ __ ] yeah that's a devil's
doberman
i want to give him a hug but he was
walking fast i was like i'm gonna see
him soon but whatever but like johnny
knoxville was there yeah that's a
[ __ ] lay into that you kind of remind
me of one of those guys in a wheel
because they have that same thing inside
of them when i was a kid
and i used to like i just called my hair
yesterday it was
like almost double as yours you've had a
lot of styles bring up that photo nick
can you bring it up
the photo calling i sent you i just got
like the people changing password for
for for different accounts
dude that's what you do with your hair i
wasn't changed that password to your
brain yesterday i was like i was looking
at the mirror and i was like don't carry
you look good like that it's not about
looking good it's about being a new
person and i was like you don't like to
[ __ ] every every two weeks and she
was just laughing about it because i i
really changed my hair like every
four or six months oh you've had a lot
of different styles do you have it colin
but going back to like what you say
about johnny knoxville
steve all
everybody used to call me stevo when i
was a kid really like she used to come
like cheeto like because i would do just
dumb [ __ ] here you go
this is definitely
you could be a lit you could be like a
criminal who goes on the run you know
you're hiding from the fbi
you know
when i was a kid
watching the guns like the guns or
movies from like new york and i was like
oh that's a good avenue for myself
i can i can be a great hitman yeah yeah
that's why i know my wife like me he's a
new guy every two months
[Laughter]
and i can make her laugh so
yeah well that might be the funniest
thing anybody's ever said on this
podcast that's so funny oh look i
believe
look at the guy at the top right who is
that guy that's a vikings that is a
viking
dangerous if i can this guy on the top
left maybe is also maybe
business he might be a businessman or
like a rich grandson wealthy son of like
a man
yes yes yeah i see that the guy in the
middle on the left obviously is going to
prison yeah he he was caught with some
crack and some [ __ ]
the guy on the right in the middle now
that guy is a conquistador huh
conquistador there you go yeah dude this
i'm surprised with this picture i never
saw this one and the guy on the bottom
is that you on the bottom right yeah
that was before the elder fight below
that was before jesus christ bro that
was a long time ago
that looks like it's from like the
prehistoric times yeah i saw that the
water turned into wine yeah
i saw i saw that
like you're from the jungle man that's
wild and dude i can tell you there's
like at least
six or seven myths in here oh totally i
have like fully shaved head
with without beer even the one when
you're on ariel helwani you look like a
guy just on a boat you know like a guy
from like a um
you're like that fist hippie kind of you
know like
you got my head
i'm not worried about like that's one
another thing about me
i
i'm not worried about the way i look i
go by feeling like he doesn't matter
like who who i'm going to see or who i'm
hanging out with i don't change that
like
that's why i i told joe i'm a hippie
have you always been like that
when i was a kid
i guess it's different you can't really
be a kid and be a hippie of course but i
used to when i was a kid i used to be
like cowboy boots blue jeans
jean shirt but because i because you
were on the farm i was on a farm yeah
yeah like i i would be in a farm every
week and so for me was like
that was the buy for me and i love it
like i i still having cowboy boots like
i like that but it's kind of hard going
surfing in the morning on cowboy boys
it's like yeah i got them flipped for
their birthday you don't show up to the
water with your homies and you're like
with jeans and whatever like bro are you
okay you're like good day ocean yeah you
know what i'm saying yeah so it's kind
of it's hard to keep it up in cali but
they're there they're they're safe for
me
um when you were watching last night i
know that's that stamin fight and the
nurmagomedov of that guy that's a good
fight yeah and they say he's not related
they're related let's somebody's lying
these these guys are related yeah you
can't be the same name
yeah and coming into the ufc right there
no they're they're causing somebody's
cause there's something there's
something
somebody definitely has seen somebody
naked in the family you know yeah um
when you watch that fight do you think
that there was anything else that cody
could have done to give himself a chance
or do you think that there was i
seen because i'm i'm uh i'm a [ __ ]
nerd i'm watching i know
all these guys i i watch them fight the
last couple fights and
cody i think
he tried too hard to wrestle but it's
also i think like he don't it's not like
you need to like to be hit but you know
some guys get hit and they turn up like
for example moreno you can crack the
[ __ ] with a baseball bat and he
will fire back at you curtis simon get
crack in the face and he's almost like
he goes into panic mode like when he
fought jimmy rivera he was doing well
and jimmy rivera landed a big right hand
and he was like oh [ __ ] let me wrestle
you and then it's almost like fighting
is energy man like as soon as i crack
you and you only [ __ ] you it's like okay
let's i'm in a real fight but if you
crack somebody and that person is like
you know what let's not do this you can
feel the energy oh you can oh percent
i've been there
many times and i've been here that i'm
like
[ __ ] you dude i'm gonna make your mom
cry right now is it hard when you get
hit say you take a good shot right
and you've been pretty i mean dude one
thing that's amazing about you you never
the only your only losses have been by
decision yeah thanks god unbelievable
but is it i i i credit that to my work
ethic i created to the way i eat in and
out of camp i created that to my
recovery i go to bed
at 9 30 10 like last night after the
fight it was like 11 and everybody was
like okay time to party let's go to the
club i'm like i'm not celebrating [ __ ]
tonight right like what i'm celebrating
like yeah
and even like even me and moreno share
the same manager they asked me you want
to come to after party and wing lost or
draw i like him i respect him i'm like
yeah but
he's i wouldn't even train together like
i went with the fights with my coach
we want to we want to straight back home
and i was like on sundays i do long
distance run like 13 miles so i was like
that's what i have to do tomorrow and i
set for it
but
the reason i feel i don't get a stop or
anything like that is just because i'm
my consistency and mentally i know
if i work like that
how somebody would just come and run
through me
so i skipped the same work ethic and he
paid the price
roses are red violets are blue
and you gotta take care of your uh
pubic hair
on your body you gotta do it nobody's
gonna do it for you not at this age
and that's probably good
you know it's almost unreal though that
there's nowhere you can take your balls
or your wanker into a shop and get them
to
tighten you up g out you know get you
ready for christmas or get you ready for
valentine's
but
love is around the corner
and if you want to look good
then you got to clean up your junk with
our
exclusive offer go to manscape.com
theo for the best tools
to get your balls and [ __ ] ready
and your body get the hair off your body
you don't want they'll do it
yep take care of your body your body
looks starts looking nasty you got to do
it
god ain't going to come down and get you
that fresh batch
it's your responsibility go to
manscape.com t-h-e-o
for 20 off and free shipping
they got that refined cologne they got
the lawnmower 4.0
you might want to have your wife or
somebody get it for you as a gift
or you may get it for your wife if she's
all haired out
go to manscape.com t-h-e-o for our
exclusive offer 20 off and free shipping
support the podcast happy valentine day
are you mentally unwell that's a
question i ask myself probably 60 70
times an hour
and sometimes
the answer is no
um but you do your best you fight back
you battle back
as we're learning in today's episode
you gotta fight you gotta be a fighter
better help can help you
if you're not doing good if you don't
you know
if you haven't washed your body in a
couple months days or months
and if you haven't even touched your
hair you're afraid to look at yourself
you don't feel good your heart feels
soiled like it should be wearing a
diaper
betterhelp.com
they have licensed therapists mental
health people that can be there for you
and really
really help you you know they want you
to get well and and you want to get well
so this is the place
for those two possibilities to meet each
other
go to betterhelp.com t-h-e-o to be
connected with a licensed professional
therapist
it's
secure it can be private nobody has to
know you don't have to go to that small
weird building in your town
they've helped over 2 million people
betterhelp.com t-h-e-o
to get 10 off your first month
that's right 10 off for this past
weekend listeners this podcast is
sponsored by better help
it's interesting it's almost like it
feels like you're in the cage even when
you're not in the cage
that's kind of the idea
i live like that and i'm i'm always
thinking
i i sort of got to wake up every morning
thinking i'm gonna have a tough fight
coming up i don't i don't let none of
this
uh cloud or every fight you get to get
more known by the world i don't let none
of that come to me like i enjoyed school
i make money i i get bigger fights i get
a recognition i get to hang out with
people i i love but
fighters i think is the only sport
there's other ones but i think it's the
only one that you cannot [ __ ] around
i know surfers that parry go hard the
next day they win a hit i know guys i
know soccer players they're [ __ ]
going crazy
doing coke doing whatever everything's
particularly sparring
they look [ __ ] bad diet whatever
sugar they look [ __ ] great
basketball i don't know no one there but
i'm sure you can drink a little bit
before the game oh i think a lot of
those guys i'm friends with blake
griffin and he said they had a guy on
his team used to smoke cigarettes before
the game man see
fighting is too gnarly to [ __ ] around
fighting is too crazy
you're in a cage the energy is only one
against one like
it's too much
to risk
is there an animal that you ever see
that reminds you of you like a fight
like that reminds you of fighters or
that like i'm a monkey yeah a crazy
energetic monkey you've always felt like
that my whole life
when i was a kid i was really good
climbing trees like i would love to get
in the top of the mango trees and just
chill that i would like sit on like on
the top of a route for like hours and
you just chill there like yeah dude the
abuse of [ __ ]
it's beautiful oh do they have and they
have do people do is monkey like a food
even in ecuador or no they know we just
eat cows and [ __ ] pork we don't
[ __ ] wrong we don't eat dogs we don't
need nothing nothing wild no
like if like if you go to the i heard
like a guy that used to work for me that
they used to eat a snakes but
[ __ ] i think that's just more for fun in
one town in ecuador they eat something
called koi
it's basically it's red oh it's rat it's
like looks like a ride to me i am and
i've been in that town and they're like
you wanna i'm like no
oh it's delicious i don't give a [ __ ]
right a steak takes a leisure student
i'm sticking to that
i
i leave the kuya side i don't [ __ ]
around there yeah yeah you never seen a
cow in a in a dumpster you know so
that's the thing you know that's true
too um
what were we talking about oh we're
talking about that fight do you think
that there was anything that stamin
could have done to get out to get in a
better situation i think when he hit the
single
it was almost like he don't hit the
single to take him down he was more to
don't get hit and that's why probably it
was just so easy to sing the choke and
let's be also honest those russians guys
came pretty prepared
he like a necktie right this this
nurmagomedov in a specific have a really
good spinning wheel kick so like he hit
him he started fighting with two hard
ones like the moment somebody did that
to you
i saw he get hurt a little bit and he
kind of like was like [ __ ]
you throw that two to me i'm in your
face i'm like i'm gonna try to take your
head off right away because it's energy
like if somebody hit you that hard and
you kind of like
don't do nothing about it you let them
get a step ahead let them get a step
ahead
so no i do see what you're saying like i
mean i don't know i mean you know like
uh
but i know what you're saying like i
always wonder yeah what the energy is
like in there because we just see the
fight you know it's hard to get a an
idea of what that mono-imano like it's a
conditioning you have to pretend
sometimes do you have to almost like you
have to keep this force field up even if
there's something that hurt do you have
to like keep an energy right there i'm
gonna say it's okay to be here like
we're not invisible we got
we're not meant for fighting but
once you decide that you're gonna be
your life the moment you get hurt you
gotta either go for a walk you gotta
either step on the gas but you cannot
just try to avoid the fight because
your opponent will notice that no it's
you can't you can see the collars like
like like mortal kombat you know when
you get hit goes down it's almost like
you can sense that and
wow i'm really good at least with that i
can i can tell when my opponent
it's ready to die like he's a hard
[ __ ] guy or it's a guy that is kind
of like you know what
you can take me out today i'm going to
live another day wow you do can tell
that because
you can be winning in a fight and the
other guy
lands one and then the guy that is
winning kind of wobble
you can see how that thing shifts like
whoop completely moving and
that's when you have to like even when
you hurt you you have to
learn how to fight the worst thing is
when somebody get hurt and start
swinging i'm like oh protect yourself
before you start swinging yeah but um
you know not everybody gotta
get the brain pretty focused at the
moment most people is fit but
how many people is actually training
their minds to be ready ready especially
when they're in
real turmoil when they're really pained
out yeah like i've been heard before
i've i've been here like
in the head in the body i've been like
somebody threw a log and i feel my knees
like
completely dead and i'm like you gotta
figure it out you gotta make sure
you figure it out and
you can only do that if you're prepared
to be there like
some people i see some people don't
really train him for a family why are
you doing this yeah go do something else
right why get your ass kicked in front
of the whole world
just because you're a [ __ ] lazy [ __ ]
who is the best fighter you ever trained
with that didn't train that hard do you
think cause you trained with some
interesting cats man yeah i i've been i
shared much with
really high level people
i think um
all the good guys i train with they ho
they
they all have a pretty sad mentality of
like this is it for me like i'm not
i'm not going to in and out after
inspiring me right
and honestly with me
if you are a person that you're not
trying
to be on top of your game
it's almost like i stopped hanging out
with you like
i don't i don't i don't do it in a mean
way but i'm like if you're not
willing to be better and
leave the people around you
i'm just not interested in you like i
just literally i just want to get back i
just want to get better and everything
in life like just be be a better person
be nice to people be kind you know you
can be a world champion and if you treat
like [ __ ] everybody i don't want to hang
out with you i don't want to be around
that [ __ ] because it's like
even if i'm not like that and i let you
be like that
i'm part of it so
in mo in all senses like i just want to
be around people that is happy and he's
just doing something to be better like
that because yeah because that is all
that'll only help you wow that's fine
i don't i don't want to waste my time
like even if you are a famous person and
you're a piece of [ __ ] i'm like
i don't want to be part of that yeah
it's not worth it there's no reward on
that so
for me it's it's more about that than
anything else
when you look at like where you're at
now with fighting and you look at um
your division is there
is there a fight that kind of tempts you
as their fight like i know people talk
about cruz people talk about o'malley
people talk about um
who's up there san hagen's in your
division isn't he yeah
i think
i think that was a fight to make i get
offered send hug in february 19 really
mainly ben and it never happened i
definitely don't think
he
run away from the fight he's a he's a
solid fighter but i think he's hurt or
something like that
so he may need more time he just had
that big he had a big fight against yon
yeah that was a great fight that was a
great fight but maybe he needed surgery
i don't know but
when they offered me that
it didn't took me like a minute to say
like you send the contract
and then that never happened so
i don't want to waste time i'm ready to
go right do you feel like you get enough
fights and
yeah i fight three three times a year
normally this past year i did twice but
when you get to the point like you're
fighting like edgar all those guys
you can fight six times a year you're
fighting the top guys you have to use
way for the top guys right because
there's guys that they're not ranked
like when i wasn't ranked the guys in
the top 10 don't want to fight me
there's no reward right and i get it
it's a business so i don't
i don't cry about it
it near end even when i when i was low
or when i'm high so now i just gotta
wait for a top five guy
or something that that makes sense and
what fight is ah what fight is still ha
because i don't even know if there's any
band and weight fights on the docket
right now are there no not right now
like i think uh
jaddong is fighting mariah's but they're
below me anyway
uh
the only guys ahead of me is mirab font
sun hagen
aldo and cruz yeah and cruzy crying like
three four times already
he's
he you you guys aren't gonna fight you
don't think oh they call me they offer
us to fight multiple times he's an
interesting guy he's kind of like um he
reminds me of like uh he almost reminds
me of tom cruise the actor
because he like he's had a great career
you know he's had all these he's had a
really illustrious career long career
and he's also this kind of like unique
mysterious kind of dude you know he
when i hear him talk he sounds
he sounds too smart like he tried to
like say
perfect things and be perfect and he
took his time
but um i don't know him personally like
we do the commentary he does in english
i got in spanish so we cross path often
and i call him out all the time but
i just keep it real when i see him i say
i say what's up you know if he said [ __ ]
you then i guess we're fighting right
he's not like that anyway but do you
think he wants that fight maybe there's
because it hit for him at this point
it's kind of what does he want to do
really for honestly a guy like that i'm
guessing he's just he's just one big
fight right but
you know
he he's coming off a win i'm coming off
a win i think makes sense because it's
just i think his number is six or
something like that he's not too high up
there
but they offer us to fight three times
already and he just declined it
so when somebody declared that much i'm
not losing my time right you can't keep
calling it maybe it's just not what they
want no especially if maybe yeah you
know sometimes you don't know i guess
maybe what the fighter's plan is or what
their path is yeah that's why like i'm
i tell them like just just send me the
contract with anybody higher than me and
on its own like it's a striker or
wrestler and i'm training everything so
i'm not worried about
specific things
we had a question that came in here
right here um
[Music]
here we go
you can see it that good but you'll be
able to see it enough i think
oh we're gonna need the headphones for
this yes sir we can hear him for sure
what's up cheeto um
oh and theo cheeto theo dio chito i
don't know
uh i just wanted to ask this that fight
against sean o'malley every single time
i just keep talk not talking but hearing
about it and i have to keep talking
about how
honestly you won the fight
so my question is
when are you gonna get the ballot when
are you gonna go for the belt to be
honest that's the real question
but uh no yeah honestly cheeto i'm a
huge fan um i think you just kind of
answered that really too i think even
just
like you were saying the only yeah what
would the path for you to get to the
belt be like i wonder
i i believe at the moment
if i get a fight with somebody in the
top five i'ma fight away from there
because
either my fight with aldo even if i lost
that fight by decision
coming coming to the third round he was
pretty defeat he was very tired and
after that i get i get too cocky i get
too excited and i pay the price of that
i went too hard too fast he took my back
and he hold me there so
i will never sit down and it was um i'm
putting excuses like oh he just hold me
down no i'm right it's your
responsibility i'm the idiot that
couldn't get out yeah and i put myself
in that position so i i just take it
like a man
and i definitely work on that i've been
uh
i took like six months working on don't
get hold in that specific position and i
i believe i figured it out even when
frankie took my back i was like out
quick
so
that was
something that i'm glad i i fixed and an
improvement yeah and after that aldo
went and kicked uh funds us
he beat up munoz pretty well so that
just put me in a good position because
he couldn't do none of that to me
against you yeah so
that can set on set us up for a rematch
easily i feel
i can do a fight for tower elimination
with him or i can just fight somebody
like marab that is a a tough wrestler
nobody can beat him lately and he can
take you down and hold you down so if i
go in there and i just
put him out
like simple because no one called him
out right for reasons
he's not popular
he's boring but he's effective he wins
right he don't talk [ __ ] but he wins
right so if i go in there and just
clean cut
put him out
stomp him yeah okay that that's how you
that's a crazy [ __ ] that you do and
people is like [ __ ] this guy's real
right because i'm not worried about
anybody it's not like some fighters are
like they have a path to the title
that is very well done like okay fight
this guy he's a heavy puncher okay you
clinch him okay now you're fighting a
good grappler don't go to the ground
right i'm willing to fight
good or bad fights because i know one
thing if you're ready you have a chance
to put him on you have a chance to
get away with something i'm not worried
about the striker or the wrestler
because i i i do it all
do you ever sometimes you're in there do
you ever forget that you do you like
kicking or punching more that's when
sometimes i'm always wondering do these
guys like to kick more or punch more do
you ever forget that
we'll answer that first you like to kick
or punch more
i like both like i don't like now that
i'm with perillo um he's a great boxer
i feel my punches are getting pretty
crisp and that just helps my kicks to be
better because if i can punch you i can
click
some people have no punching and just
kick right yeah but then when somebody
put a good comb on them they get clipped
so i feel like now that i've i get my
boxing my bass pretty good i can kick
better than before just because i fix
little mechanics with him and
i feel like
i'm very complete now i feel like there
are things like people who want to take
me down now which
i train with one of the best people in
the world on the ground anyway so i'm
not even
i'm just not worried right like i'm and
there are things like some people is
very talented but then you can get them
tired
good luck trying to get me tired like
yeah just good luck with that yeah that
never happened it's not gonna happen
he's never happened before it's never
happened probably since you were born
man i think
yeah because
yeah
i'm a very active person so i'm like
if you want to get me tired i can
guarantee you will get tired in the
process and it's just a mindset like
yeah i'm willing to get a heart attack
that's what i think when i'm running
when i'm sprinting when i'm sparring
like i'm just pushing the pace you're
willing to have a heart attack all the
time that's what i told myself when i'm
doing a sprint when i'm sparring
i'm a human i feel the same [ __ ] you
feeling
but i can control that feeling i can
tell myself it's okay to feel like that
i just make friends with
with those demons and he's like wow i
just keep them close because
i can tell you
all the crazy [ __ ] in the world i can
lie to you i can tell you
[ __ ]
that my dick is bigger four inches more
than normal is but i will never lie to
myself so you gotta keep it real i have
the same feeling my chest is burning my
legs are tired my forearm are gas
but it's okay
it's just okay i like that idea of
making friends with those things you
know you have to of keeping those demons
close yeah when i get to the part where
my heart's beating i'm just like damn i
might die but you say hey
i say that it's cool to feel dead and
just keep going wow what's gonna happen
have a heart attack that's not losing
you know what i'm saying yeah that's not
losing no no that's just one round is
when you break your leg right i'm not
saying i want that to happen to me but
if you kick somebody in your leg
snapping twice
you're not getting i they say tko but
it's not like somebody right it's not
like somebody kicked your ass some
something really bad happened to you in
the process so when i'm throwing a kick
or a punch
that's a mindset i have i'm like i'm
gonna break myself through you yeah and
it works pretty good when you um
when
when you were in the o'malley fight did
you feel like
at the end of that fight that he had
given
when you got him on the ground you're on
top of did you feel like he'd given up
at that point did it feel like that
because obviously he was injured like he
was injured and that happened the same
to uh cejuro happened to chandler right
before so
it happened to me but in my arm like
young lineker punched like a truck and
he punched me in the elbow and my arm
will numb
it's at this like i'm not a doctor but i
think like this if a nerve get affected
and you start like panicking your nerve
your season goes firing up so i was just
telling myself like my arm was numb just
take my time just run around a little
bit clench him whatever my arm going
back to normal so i was just like it is
okay to have something like that right
to have that happen we actually sean
actually sent this question in and let's
see
is it okay if we play it i don't want
you to feel like we have to oh bro come
on okay cool let me see what he's doing
saying and look he's literally we just
put it he just sent it in through like
the regular channel he didn't send it to
me he just sent it i believe that
through the dropbox let's see what he
say
cheetah what up bro it's your friend
chickashawn i'm just wondering if uh you
actually thought you won that one fight
uh let me know your thoughts i will theo
says he doesn't think it counted no no
got it
i did not say that it's cool like that's
another thing about me i won't get
offended by that [ __ ] oh i didn't say
but i i know you didn't okay but if you
were if you told me bro i don't think
you want to fight i'm like cool no i
just i was re-watching it the other day
and i was just i don't know what it's
like to be in a fight like that right so
i was wondering if
if i'm
you know if i'm something happens to me
where i feel impaired right do i then
get into a situation where i
give where i'm just like it's i'm out
i'm going to live to fight another day
right or and then if you're in the ring
with them do you are you able to know
that you know when
when i when the fight started and i
started walking towards him like most
guys kind of like running away from him
he's rendy and he can be clowney he come
like i dyed my hair colorful
many times too
we look funky and people sometimes like
because you have pink in your hair
you're not
tough or something that's your looks
like
um most people think
he's not training he's [ __ ] around
he's
just another fighter doing his job doing
whatever right people get full by the
way we act if you hear all the [ __ ] i
say sometimes you would think i'm not
this person but it's just the easy way
i'm talking [ __ ]
99 of the day yeah and most of the time
i don't mean none of that i'm just
talking [ __ ] right
people
get fooled by that like when i was when
i was fighting him and he was talking
i don't have one day that i sit down and
pay attention to anything i was like i'm
gonna [ __ ] see in the cage bro yeah
and i am the type of person that let's
see he pop up right now and he says
something i don't like
i'm not sitting down i'm gonna [ __ ]
go and throw at him yeah like right away
yeah i don't have those issues so that's
why
this [ __ ] talking or promise
he don't give me or take nothing away
from me right it's just normal and
shawn's a real master of communication
he's a great like uh he's doing a good
job he's doing a good job he's a great
character he's a great character good
for him um like i'm not and fighter and
he's a great and he's a great fighter he
can fight but yeah did you feel like you
won at the end that was yeah i i wasn't
mad or bog aboard the way he went i
kicked him in the leg
he should give up that wasn't an injury
during his angle that wasn't the same
thing that happened when he fought
sukanta
which
zukunta
if you're [ __ ] upon half a broken
foot why you take him down bro like why
you don't let him stand up and just kick
his ass
but
that's also what they call
being a little smart in the fight like
my opponent break his feet while you
take him down you're making him a favor
right just just just let him yeah
and the referee will stop it
when i was walking him down
i found his energy
he don't he don't like pressure and most
guys
want to go too crazy at him i took my
time yeah like he throw punches but i
saw them coming he's very he's very
sharp with his hands but if you're calm
and cool you can see them coming you
know i don't close my eyes in there well
i don't think you close your eyes to
anything in the world it doesn't seem
like um
do you
have they pitched you that fight again
yeah they offered me to fight him uh
when he fought in the mcgregor car
oh yeah i was at that fight oh against
that the the green hair boy yeah the
green airport man he never fought again
wow yeah that guy
he's still getting hit somewhere that
guy took a lot of hits yeah he can take
punches in the face yeah but that also
say
like if you punch somebody that many
times
you don't punch it at her right he he or
miley snappy i give him that but if you
punch somebody that many times
that's a good point though yeah bro that
guy guy he punched him as many times as
you could punch somebody i don't think
you could punch somebody any more times
i don't know even if you knew somebody
their whole life and you didn't like
them i don't think you could punch them
no no no
that was awful that was an awful fight
i'm like
like what type of competition is that
and i think that's also why people talk
[ __ ] on him which i don't give a [ __ ]
what people say or not about him but
going back
i think i won yeah um
i was happy with it but i also leave it
in the past i don't leave off that [ __ ]
right i don't give a [ __ ] who he is or
what he does for living
i move on they call me in
last last year you want to fight him in
july i was like
this is what this is what i did and this
is what my coach advised it was a good
point she's like chito you know you
fight
anybody like no problem
told ufc
to call him first
and see what happened
they never call that game
so
and do you feel like um
do you feel like there's anybody else in
that
that's go like do you ever feel like
like because you kind of came in as
cejudo was kind of leaving out right
like yeah do you ever wish that you that
that would be a cool fight is there
anybody that's kind of like that was
right before your time or somebody that
you're like man that would have been
some not really not really like i don't
you just kind of live in the present
sort of yeah like i'm not thinking like
i we sometimes i wish i got to met guys
that retired things like that in other
way classes but people that i could
fight i don't i don't really give a [ __ ]
like
favor at some point was trying to fight
me
and then kind of like
uriah yeah because you guys fought a few
times right three couple times no don't
fight y'all never fought i i fought at
his guy i [ __ ] up all of his guys but
he at some point he was like i want to
make a comeback and fight you who did he
fight a few times cruz now yeah cruz
they fought three times didn't they now
yeah yeah he lost the person and
he won the first one
yeah one was in l.a when rocco fought
bisping
and their one was with the green muscle
fight with the the the second fight was
in the in the ufc with the green muscle
firing cage
um
yeah that's uh
you're right has that [ __ ] that dude
is his hands are so crazy um yeah he
broke both of his hands against mike
brown and now lizzy
dude his hands are so his hands as they
they they
they're like the biggest thing i've ever
seen you almost got to use two hands
yeah but he's also four feet tall so
he's not gonna look bigger yes you know
what i'm saying maybe it's proportional
he's got some real mitts on him though
yeah he can play catcher without a
freaking without a mitt man he's got
some real mitts on him um
yeah so i guess it's kind of interesting
because it's like in your division it's
like how do you
because there's not even any fights
coming up so
do you feel like you're gonna have to
sit and wait do you feel like you're
going to have to fight somebody that's
lower rank than you or what do you think
you're going to have to do because
there's not even any i don't think in
the next four or five cards there's even
a bantamweight fight on the uh on the
horizons
no
he's used them
he's just jam fighting starling in
april i believe yeah in florida
and then that's about it
i've been i i saw sean last night and i
was like hey man i want to [ __ ] i
know everybody break your balls before
they ask you for anything let me say hi
shake his hand give him a hug i was like
did you have a date and don't give me
don't give me a name he's like you
fighting soon i'm like cool wow that's
all i need to know
because everybody wanna [ __ ]
bug his eyes like you're like
i don't have time for [ __ ] cry to
nobody i'm like hey just just say a date
he's like you're fighting soon
we cool
um
when you like what would you have think
of been if you hadn't been a fighter
when you think back on like what are you
really because you if you were working
in that place doing the papers right
that's a pretty
i would i tell you this right now i will
never have a shitty job like that i will
have something cooler like that i
wouldn't mind being a farmer dude like
the daily work the fastest farmer you
would be the fastest [ __ ] farmer
yeah your work would be done i could see
like the ox would be out there and you
would be out there next to him you know
yeah yeah
i think i could work with my dad that
would be easy but i just like i i i oh
when i was a kid i always thought like
whatever whatever i end doing i'm just
gonna
do it cool and be good at it like i just
i always have good energy like i feel
like whatever they i have to do
it doesn't matter i'm gonna just do it
right all right guys you know there's
only four teams left in the nfl playoffs
right now four teams and
jesus who thought they'd be some of
these teams i didn't you know i never
expected some of this i can't even
believe some of these cities have teams
but they do
there's four teams left and draftkings
sportsbook
wants to give you an opportunity
they're the official sports betting
partner of the nfl
super bowl 56
is on the horizon new customers can get
56 to 1 odds on any team
bet just five dollars and get 280
dollars in free bets if your team wins
that's a big upswing
that's that money maker you bet just
five next thing you know down
you could take your family somewhere
take them to uh
take the kids to a carousel get them a
chocolate
if you're not a new customer you can
experience the conference championships
with same game parlays
so if you're not new there's still an
option
you can combine multiple bets from the
same game for a bigger payout that's
what i like doing you know pick this
you know jerry isn't gonna wear his
shoes so that's you know seventy dollars
if it happens
draftkings is safe secure and reliable
download the draftkings sportsbook app
now use promo code
t-h-e-o and get 56-1 odds on any nfl
team bet just five dollars and win 280
in free bets if your team wins that's
promo code t-h-e-o for 56-1 odds at
draftking sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the nfl must be 21 or
older new jersey indiana or pennsylvania
only new customers only minimum five
five dollar deposit and one dollar wager
required
one per customer restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
called 1-800 gambler does something
start to pop in your head as sometimes i
notice as i get older like something
kind of comes in my head like oh this
might be a peaceful thing to do later
down the line do you start thinking
about that like after fighting i mean
i feel like you still have a long career
um but yeah i'm i'm i'm just 29 so
there's for sure like i have at least
five gears that i can make myself a lot
of fights i can make myself um
put in a good legacy make history and
just keep kicking ass but
i think about sometimes like what you
want for afterwards and i'm like
you know probably i'm gonna start
collecting
businesses or whatever me and my wife we
thought about it we wanted like at some
point when i'm opening like a like a
small cute coffee shop let's make it all
pretty put some art around
sell some some some some accessories
whatever cool
we live in college so there's a bunch of
cool coffee shops and uh we've been
thinking for years like maybe one day we
open up one and we use chill that'd be
cool that'd be cool
i'm or you never know did you win a
fight and then somebody called you for a
movie somebody called you for a
something crazy
with life you you never know i always
tell myself just just keep being you
keep doing cool [ __ ] and things will
come up your way so
i'm not i'm not really too worried about
it like i i feel some people is too
worried about
where where they want to go wow they
they're nerve focusing right now you
know what i'm saying that's me you're
talking to that guy really yeah a lot of
times yeah i just get caught like in
just worrying a lot that's why it's
really nice to be around you because
just like it's inspiring man to like
be seem so to meet someone who seems so
comfortable in the space that they're in
uh
it's in it's it's it's it's inspiring i
think it's uh i and i get this from you
know there's a lot of people around like
joe rowan is a
perfect example like i've been listening
to him since before i moved to the u.s
and that's like
seven years ago
and you know seven years ago he wasn't
the [ __ ] guy that is now yeah but he
he always talk about it
you know it's almost when your boxing
coach told you back to basic work in the
job the job cross in life is also the
same thing like you can be
desperate for what's coming or you can
be like thinking like oh i want to be
this i want to be this yes we got it we
all want to do something in life unless
you're a [ __ ] lazy piece of [ __ ]
but
but if you're really putting your energy
in something
it's just you know get the lessons from
the past
and [ __ ] enjoy today because
most
most people or some people they don't
have a tomorrow you know they're sick
with cancer
they
lost everything we don't know so i
always tell myself if i if i have if i'm
alive i have a chance yeah and then
it's weird like i think that mentality
definitely was what took me here but
even when i was a kid
and i was having a problem at issue or i
wasn't getting something done
i just told myself there's always a way
there's always a chance just figure it
out like
when you do you miss being a child you
talk about being a kid a lot i talk
about being a kid a lot on on on this
show uh
do you miss it like do you think it was
fun like do you have a lot of great
memories from being a kid i have yeah i
do have great memories i don't but i
don't want to be back i remember when i
used i was in high school and i was like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] i hate to be sitting here
to listen a [ __ ] person to telling me
two plus two is four
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
teacher and then everybody was like bro
when
when high school is done you're gonna
miss it so much
the day i graduated from high school i
say [ __ ]
you and until today i'm like i don't
want to go back to that i was just not
made to be sitting down
and learning a [ __ ] equation yeah
which
that thing will do nothing for you like
they don't teach nothing
in a school
not for you not for a guy like you yeah
yeah yeah specifically i don't i'm not
talking normal people but but yeah i had
to do i do i remember doing steroids to
do math how to do steroids bro i'm not
even joking we used to do steroids just
to do you know and i would do math real
good that year and
um but it's just like it just wasn't for
me like i was like
teach me something about life like teach
me how to
handle
what's out there in the jungle like
right this [ __ ] equation is not these
these not books are not gonna take me
out of problems like oh yeah i don't see
when i look at you i don't think i think
if i see a book and i see a jungle yeah
you're like the jungle you're the guy
looking at the kid looking out the
window being like i want to take on the
jungle most people don't think that way
yeah well that's true too but they don't
but in any snr in life in any profession
you pick
you can keep the energy of like
don't get desperate on the goal
right be
beyond the process take care of the
process like it's all about the process
like if you do the process wrong
the recipe whatever
the end will be bad the taste of the
food will be but
your whatever your your goal was you
won't you won't get it done just because
you were
you were thinking in something else yeah
like you cannot be thinking on on the
finish line if you're not doing nothing
in the starland yeah yeah that's true
huh
did you all have halloween growing up
over there did you guys have halloween
yeah
we don't it's not as hardcore as the u.s
like
you know every house is packed we got a
we definitely got a halloween party but
we don't have like the whole city giving
convention but we got some
you know some places uh-huh that some um
communities that does it but it's not
like the u.s like
it's almost like christmas
did they have what's like a unique
ecuador holiday that they have that we
don't have is there something kind of
well new years and christmas for us it's
a full-on party really it's like music
whiskey and good food it's full on power
like christmas for and christmas for us
is we open the presents on the 24
night time when everybody's drunk the
25th is just
play with the toys already open
and mom and dad is hungover yeah it's a
little different there but it's fun dude
the food is great
similar food just with a different
little different stuff
like you know the turkey everything but
great food do you miss it do you miss
ecuador a lot you have i love awkward
dude like
i haven't been able to go since 2019 wow
because of covet i was going after each
fight to do
either a commercial or a picture for a
brand whatever
because of coffee it's just you know we
haven't been able to go back was it
awesome to see that guy last night
morales i think his name a michael
morales michael morales wow dude he's an
athlete dude
like
he went and just threw a hate maker oh
wow he's a welterweight he's a big boy
but he's 22 years old like i remember
when i married to the ufc 21
so i cannot i can't i can relate it in
mind how he feels
you feel like
you're on top of the world we came from
a small country and i'm in the ufc since
2014 yeah
2022 we got the second one
so it's been a long time wow so
but that kid whatever he's doing
keep it up because he's doing well did
he reach out to you for any suggestions
or
he's
before the ufc
uh i think kind of like he the the
person now we have the same monitor but
like the manager whatever he have an
ecuador or his team they were like
tagging me every day on sunday trying to
get you to see him and i was like i know
who he is
but there's nothing i can do like like
what do you want me to do like
you don't worry that but people
sometimes don't know right right yeah
they don't know they don't yeah i mean
why you want me to call dana and he
fights next week you don't work like
that right but
i the only thing i say is like just keep
it up like if you if you're doing right
by yourself you you will get there
and what i've been saying since
four three years ago is like if you want
to be in the ufc we don't have the
sources in ecuador we don't have the
teammates we don't have
a solid team so
once you figure it out you win like
three fights
get the [ __ ] out go if you don't have a
visa go to brazil or go to mexico he
went to mexico with brandon and there's
like four other ecuadorians within
brandon's team i'm like
finally i remember people will talk [ __ ]
like what the [ __ ] you say echo or suck
i'm not saying that but we don't have
nothing there for us you don't have the
infrastructure they don't even really
have it we don't have it do they have
gems now mma gyms it's get they have to
be getting a little bit better yeah this
is the thing we have good wrestling we
have good boxing we have
pretty good jiu-jitsu like
after brazil it's a quarter in south
america introduced
put it together good luck doing that
it's just it's a different game like i
can be due to world champion and still
getting choked down in the ufc it
happened to roll for vietnam yeah you
know what i'm saying like
you have to put it together so if you're
a good wrestler
and you have a couple of fights
migrate go go and train with real
fighters we don't have that and
it's not like i'm happy that what i say
works but
all of the guys that left right they're
doing well one already made it and
there's there's a pair of twins that
they're [ __ ] good that
this kid i don't know him like i see him
last night i say good luck blah blah but
i don't i don't know him personally
there are the twin kids they trade with
me before i left ecuador i know them and
they're close to make it
so i'm like
if you are
if you left the country and you make it
now
now i don't say [ __ ] you right you were
saying no no literally oh man i think
you were right well and also we're
talking about ecwid it's like the only
way to get people to talk about where
you're from if it's not extremely
popular is to get
to a place where people can see
you talking about that place right you
know it's like yeah sometimes people are
like loyal to their town to a fault
you know you can't do that yeah because
it will only take you to failure like
like you cannot sacrifice your whole
life just because you say
my country's better than yours like
right i'm in the u.s like things will
never change i walk up to with my flag
all the time even when they say it's
fighting out it doesn't say it's
fighting out of california still said
those
small details were there forever right
but i wouldn't be kicking frankie in the
face
turning in ecuador right i can guarantee
you that we got another question or two
that came in here let's bring up
something good here
[Music]
i um we just
oh my hair wasn't like that what's up
theo what's up cheeto in anticipation
for tonight what was your favorite
moment from ufc 271
gang gang gang baby and i think he means
270 probably yeah you're in the future
bro yeah uh
that was through dmt or mushrooms
like 271 who's
he's not even announced that look that
guy was there apparently it was like a
good time [ __ ] i wish we should facetime
him who wasn't very bad in that car
well for but but i can tell my favorite
moment from last night to 70.
i definitely think when moreno woke out
that [ __ ] arena turn dude i've been
in many years and last night
when he woke up it was like i thought i
was in tijuana yeah
i was like [ __ ] this is a lot of [ __ ]
mexicanos here i was like this is great
like
that you can feel like sometimes people
make noise but it almost feels like when
mcgregor workout
you know
it's just when he woke up he's huge so
he feels like
pretty dense that was one thing people
love him
and it's just you know it's like
people love him and meg i mean
yeah mexican people don't get enough
credit in this country and mexican
people keep this country they keep this
going and
who bro every day people should start
the morning by just applauding
mexican people bro i don't know i do not
know
i don't know what would be going on if
there weren't for mexican people dude
and
that is probably
pretty up there and also
this country is made by immigrants yes
yeah people forget that over time you
forget that it's always been that way
it's always been the way yeah like joe's
talks about like
his family came from italy like or or
stuff like that like
this country is is is it's a mix of
goods
yeah my father came from nicaragua
actually in uh
20 no 1910.
my dad was really old when i was born
but he came here in 1910 or no in 1922
he came here but he was born in 1910
but he came from central america here
see it's all yeah the whole it's always
been that way but that's that's why
that's why they say
america yeah it's not
the usa it's
america's the [ __ ] continent like
south america central america like
these countries it got a little bit of
the best of everything yeah um yeah and
look and it's got opportunity you know
it just has opportunity um
and people will come off from anywhere
to get it what was there another great
moment from that that you enjoyed from
last night last night
yeah what do you think of that other uh
the i'm thinking of the moreno the
outcome
i
is
i hate when i know the guys because i
want them to win and if i was so close
i think i think they could give it to
him
but also
um
what's his name figueretto was being
smart on don't throw first
because he will be counter pretty easy
so he was almost waiting for big shots
and there was two different rounds if
i'm gonna run he'd touch him
and mourinho went down i think one of
them
wasn't a real
one one was a real knock down when he
put the choke and 10 seconds left
that choke was fully sync so that was
really scary was he saved by the bell
you think there
maybe
i we have to say yes because he was like
he couldn't scramble now but it was
fully on and then
he ran out of time so that was a good
thing for moreno
but then there was one that he get
touched with a job and he
went to the ground but he was more like
odd balance but we don't know that it
can be a real knockdown
and then
i think the referee i think it was
three to two maybe because of that but
moreno put more and since i was there i
saw
uh figuero
pretty hurt more than once like almost
ready to go down but i
i just feel like
mourinho was being very patient if you
if you were to step in the gas i think
he could finish him
and do you think that's something that
you learn as a fighter if you're in
there like not to like to be careful of
your counter punches like sometimes you
you learn like oh
when i counter or when i punch first
they're countering better like
especially the last fight like like uh
figure came pretty strong and mourinho
just countered him until he just took
him down and finished him and this time
he he wasn't that aggressive he was
waiting more from ren and those low
kicks also
were pretty heavy
it was an exciting fight it was a great
last 20 seconds before they just said
let's go they went max holloway ricardo
llamas they point to the ground say [ __ ]
you
it was a great fight dude it was a great
fight
the whole crowd was bowing heavy so
if you if it will be a clean decision
there i don't think the crowd will will
boot that bad
i i felt like that i felt like if it was
a ti i feel like they may should maybe
just made it a draw
exactly like they make the first time
like a draw would be great but
being a judge is a shitty job i i know
they sometimes like they make oh like
that wasn't
like that could go to moreno but
sometimes they make some decisions
you're like which fight you were looking
like yeah like that but like the whole
world gets crazy on it yeah and
but being a judge is a cheating job and
none of those guys
are martial artists none of those guys
have a full background that's crazy
isn't it
most of the
there's one referee the one judge that i
got to talk to him and i asked him like
like where you came from like like right
what you know about mma he's like yeah
i'm a boxing referee i'm like
oh you're [ __ ] then who isn't a boxing
referee yeah i'm like so everybody here
yeah like you have to separate no
headbutts and i guess no not big punches
and they're not clinching of course but
but that's just like crime like i feel
like if you go on trial for murder or
something
the people in the box should all be
murderers you know the jury
because at least then they're going to
be able to be like oh yeah he did it or
didn't if you're getting somebody that
works at a bakery or something they
don't [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
like and yeah yeah the way
love works so
it's crazy like
like just thinking about like
it's just random people saying
innocent
like
what the [ __ ] is going on like
they're working like
the judges better is better than putting
that fake hair that they used back in
the day and make a movie about it yeah
bro it is crazy the system seems a
little crazy but i don't know what else
we would do maybe let a machine do it
you know
yeah well elon musk can figure that out
yeah maybe he will like you put it your
tom prince is guilty and then you get
your your head chopped
you know some guys would be scared to
put that down i know even the the the
lie detector nothing don't work that
thing looks horrible it looks so rickety
it looks like you wouldn't even start
your car you know i'm like this thing
looked like a piece of [ __ ] you know
i the season is pretty [ __ ] up the way
things work but
somebody had one in our neighborhood
growing up had a lie detector test and
then we were always using it and [ __ ]
and it did it didn't do [ __ ] it didn't
work no people would be like i remember
asking they would ask one the kid like
are you smart and he said yes i'm smart
and we're like that dude's a [ __ ]
idiot
that thing doesn't work i think i think
we can use that on the mind yeah
we'll see man
is it interesting that the guys like uh
sean creates such a um do you get is it
hard not to try and become that kind of
energy i notice it in my own world like
i noticed some guys have bigger
personalities so sometimes i'm like do i
need to get a bigger personality um
[Music]
is it does it get tempting to try and uh
well for me it's like i think also is
where you are in life like
i
i get to the ufc
with a wife and a kid right now i have a
wife a wife and three kids so
i don't have time to go home and play
video games for five because
i got a personality i can talk to
anybody i can
you can switch up with one of those guys
and we can have a cool conversation
i can talk [ __ ] i can say
funny funky [ __ ] but when i get home
i want to play a little basket with my
son i want to take my daughters to get
an ice cream i need to take my wife
somewhere so i don't get the time i
don't have time to twitch right i don't
have time to
to do all the [ __ ] right so yeah it's
just a different it's i'm using a
different place in my life yeah like if
i would be a single guy
i'll probably be doing every single
thing i can do because i can feel like
let's see a couple months ago my wife
took the kids to palm springs for for
two days with my mother-in-law
and i was like holy [ __ ] i didn't knew
that they got so many hours
i would come back home and sit down for
six hours and be like what the [ __ ] i'm
not used to this i don't even feel good
about it even if i have time to rest
because i gotta we got a full schedule
drop the kids in high in in high school
in the school go to the gym come back
pick she go pick up one i go pick a door
go to my second practice of the day
put him to bed go to bed around 9 10
wake up
run early morning
drop somebody in the schools so it keeps
going you keep going that's your world
but like guys that don't have
the responsibilities that yeah they can
they can open what they can do like
that's that's why i put everything into
training to win fights i don't got time
to be a comedian or an actor
and i know i'm a funny person i know i
can talk [ __ ] yeah i know concocts and
jokes but
there is just not the time i could see
down the line i could see you doing it
afterwards though maybe getting into
like commentating or something you know
yeah and i do the commentary already
yeah i do for hispanics oh that's cool
man i've been doing it for like five
years oh wow that's amazing
so like i can i know i can do more [ __ ]
at the moment
it's one goal be a world champion and
just kick ass
there's
i a friend of mine used to say oh it's
like you cannot read three books in one
day so pick one
learn from it and then move into another
so like
i'm just i'm just busy
damn man yeah well this has been quite
the novella man i'm trying to think if
there's any other uh any other question
that came on colin you want to throw up
oh i like that shirt
oh yeah this guy hey come on
theo what the [ __ ] is going on bro
um my question for uh chito is
cuales
que master
theo you should probably already know
spanish from that one uh friend that you
had back in school so gang baby
yeah that uh that spanish question man
what did he ask yeah he asked me like
which is the fight that make me the most
proud
i or like or my i guess my biggest fight
i think when i went to london and fought
brad pitt
in 10 days notice was
pretty huge for my life
just because
how everything was planned out i was
coming off elbow surgery
i was fat
i was
i would call depressed i wasn't able to
show up to the gym in the la in the past
eight weeks
i had
really couple grands in the bank account
i i it was the first time
it was when we just moved for network
with my family because i came for a year
alone
train win a fight
have some money to flew my whole family
and then
i brought my family in
got the elbow surgery
and then i was sitting down in my couch
for
like seven weeks there's nothing if you
have a
elbow this big there's nothing you can
do so the moment the doctor cleared me
to start um to start running
and
basically lifting but just from my waist
down
i was i was running
every day but not not long distance i
was running heels to get my heart rate
hard like i basically become a camera
and hence for like four weeks yeah and
then i was squatting as much as i can
and
i wasn't in fighting shape but i was in
survival shape i was like
i was i was doing every day something
really hard with my legs
and then i was like [ __ ] my bank account
it's drained i don't get nothing but you
had to take it no ah thousand percent so
my money called me is like hey bro like
uh some mexican guy got hurt is bread
picker returned me and fight and i was
like
bro send the [ __ ] contract like
tomorrow like now
so
i was and i was heavy because i i wasn't
doing nothing so i was like waiting like
close to 160
and then
they told me 135 you have to make their
way i'm like i die making the way if i
have to so we flew to london
and i was basically eating
one egg
couple asparagus
and three gallons of water oh my gosh
man that was it and then back then i
didn't have the nutrition i have right
now back then was using the coaches my
manager and we're like just trying to
figure it out i was like uh what should
i eat um order the neck yeah with the
sparrow okay cool
and then we started away cut i dropped
like
close to 18 pounds
i was dead i was dead but i was broke so
i knew i have to do it
and then i get to 1 40
and i was like they asked me how are you
doing like let's just keep going
and then we gotta call hey brad takes
okay 140 because he don't want you to
pull out if you pass out and then he's
not fighting his retirement fighter
oh so they met you at 140. we met at
140. i was like cool [ __ ] it
dude walk into the cage
i was
angry i was like a madman i was like i'm
gonna kill this guy like and could you
smell people eating stuff in the stands
or not
a little bit yeah like they were saying
networks and [ __ ] you you
you will die but it was just like brazil
but in london yeah
you're fighting home time boy right
there yeah
and i was like
i was telling myself the only thing i
was thinking walk into a cage you lose
your fight you're going to send your
family back to our girl you win this
fight
you have
you don't you're not set for life
you got a year in the u.s to figure it
out and keep going because
i had like four grand walk into that
cage yeah
i was telling myself
this is gonna have to kill me like
there's no [ __ ]
turn around for me i don't want to go
back yeah i don't want to be a loser and
go back home like what happened i
couldn't make it into yours yeah
can it work for you can i clean your
house bro yeah can i be over here
there's no
accepting the [ __ ] going back
and it was a hell of a fight i think
that fight
teach me a lot about yourself about life
like what you can do when you need to do
it wow that's way now that i
i in a way have it all
like not
in
values stuff learning material [ __ ] but
i just like all my happy kids are good
wife is good
we live in cali we own houses like i'm
just i remember that
and just to keep a strong the rest of my
life like i used
i think people get
softer cocky or careless when they made
it to some point
i keep the segmentality
just
my kids can learn that one day yeah
because if
they won't remember
that in 2017 they don't know my mind
they were babies so i need to keep that
mindset for them to learn how to live
like this when they're 15 20 because if
i become a little soft [ __ ]
they will see that yeah mindset is so
it's so key with so many fighters man
it's so interesting especially in your
life man um this will be my last
question where did you meet your wife at
fourth grade
damn boy that's a little great little
creepy boy
that's early papa i know i know
who didn't touch each other till 14. so
it wasn't that's a little bit more legal
but damn boy fourth
yeah we made we made early we were in
this we were in separate classrooms
but
she always told me like i like using
something i'm like you should say
something i was ready back then
but i was i was worried about this back
then
and did you go on a date or something is
that in like in ecuador would you take a
girl on it what was that kind of like
[ __ ]
when we were young it was
it was morally going to the movies or
or just visit her at the house go for a
walk or something yeah or you know i i
was a troublemaker so they wouldn't
her her mom wouldn't let her grow up
yeah a lot
i i they put me in jail twice for
fighting in the street
so
didn't every time she was around me
their mom was like hey be careful like
like she gets you for valentine's bail
money probably
yeah every time
i'm sorry i lose it all there
yeah like i was
um i said thank god i found something
that kept me disciplined because
i only find ways to get in trouble
growing up like there
got kicked out of high school
just just looking for turn something on
fire it was just it was just trouble or
trouble over trouble and there was no
[ __ ] stuff on that that's why
you're right where you need to be i'm
right where i need to be somebody if if
if nobody will put me in a cage
i'll be [ __ ]
i don't know where it'll be bro even my
all my friends are all dumb they're all
[ __ ]
it's all [ __ ] around
oh yeah yeah
we will [ __ ] parry
since wednesday yeah i will show up to
high school drunk yeah it was just dumb
[ __ ] you were meant to be in a cage kind
of in a weird way huh a hundred percent
a hundred percent i know that and i love
it yeah i love it well man you have a
you have a beautiful life man it's been
really interesting to get to know you
it's amazing so many people really love
you uh
you know you're really beloved it feels
like in the sport and um i'm just
grateful for your time and it's really
inspiring to me where i'm at in my life
right now just appreciate it thanks for
having me dude i i've been following you
for a long time you're a funny cat well
thanks man i try my best man uh and i
hope to get to check out your next fight
man um hopefully soon yeah best of luck
brother appreciate you man thanks for
having me
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these
[Music]
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it
[Music]
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself go
that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
head
and these rails that i've been riding on
they want something that they're damn
they're
gum
[Music]